let's talk about the extreme levels
demoralization ladies and gentlemen from
kiro 7 seattle over 200
seattle police officers quit amid
national protests
in bravo bravo to each and every one of
these officers who have
quit the department and won't be party
to the corrupt system anymore
and i know we're talking about
demoralization the system falling apart
but at a certain point you need to stop
propping up the broken system
part of the demoralization exists
because these people who march to the
street with their fists in the air
have never had to deal with any real
problems because they just call the
police police do it for them
they don't actually know or care about
the police most these people in these
big cities
never interact with police but they hate
them
it's remarkable you ever actually talked
to one of these guys about their job
no but i hate them great well over in
seattle they say
spd said more than 200 officers have
left their jobs since last year
the departing officers have cited what
they call as anti-police climate in
seattle the city council police
policies and disagreements with police
department leadership
police chief adrian diaz said tuesday
the department is in what he called a
staffing crisis
it's funny it says story uh originally
by the ap but
uh not too far away from here i think
it's hagerstown
they're in a a uh police shortage as
well crisis
we also have louisville in serious
crisis
everywhere across the country serious
crisis but you know what i'm glad the
cops are leaving
these people who live in these cities
who march around and just don't
care at all their virtue signaling every
day
the reason so so let me clarify my
position for those that may not have
heard it because many of you probably
have but just very quickly
before the election it was very much
guys we need cops
we can have reform we can we can we can
get better training and better
specialties
but we need a police department and i
understand if there are things we can
change we should
i don't like it when cops enforce
unconstitutional laws
but i've lived in big cities i know what
happens when you don't have cops and you
have no one to call and
i don't know i don't think anybody
really wants that okay we made our
arguments
we watched cities burn we watched
buildings in cities burn
so that fox you know juan williams get
mad at me many buildings were destroyed
many businesses will never come back and
even in small towns
then the election happened and the
people decided you know what
i don't care about the riots you know
why because for the most part the cops
were there beating people up so i'm
going to vote for
democrats the people who actually
supported the riots bailed them out
encouraged more
now the election is over and there are
cops
who in the previous story which talked
about the feds were planning on
arresting chauvin if he was if he was
acquitted
literally if the jury was like he has
not committed he is not guilty of this
crime they'd be like arrest him anyway
the cops who are remaining are propping
all of that up
because these people who virtual signal
can only sit back
like lazy wall-e character sitting in
their hover chairs morbidly obese
they could only do that because they
know the cops are going to clean up
their mess
so if you want to be a cop in this
climate where you could potentially go
to prison or about that cop who mocked
lebron james who gets suspended without
pay according to his friend
his friend says so so we'll see how that
story comes out the police are saying
well he shouldn't have done that
you want to be you want to be a cop in
this environment you want to prop
up the corrupt politicians who i
guarantee you will
call you begging for help the moment
antifa shows up at their house
you want them to feel safe great i'll
tell you what when you resign
who do you think nancy pelosi is going
to call when antifa shows up to her
house again
they're gonna call the police what do we
do sorry ma'am there's no cops here
anymore remember how
you as a democrat wanted to defund and
and and rallied people against them
what do you think is gonna happen in
maxine's maxine waters district she's
the one who came out and told everybody
that if you see someone from trump's
administration you get in their face you
confront them
and then people did what do you think
she's going to do when auntie push us up
to her house
and she calls does i need the police uh
ma'am you
led riots against the police
there's no one to come police protection
right
and then you see lebron james imagine
this i love this lebron james is a photo
of him in new york and he's got all
these nypd guys guarding him
you want you want to know what's really
funny those cops
who protect i'll tell you this there's
two there's two two groups of cops in
in new york the cops who protect lebron
from this point forward because that
photo is probably old
the most pathetic sniveling groveling
losers if if if i was a cop
and i got a call and said hey we got
lebron james coming in can you guard him
i'd be like
no nice try dude he's on his own
he doesn't want our help what what's
gonna happen someone's gonna pull out a
knife i'm gonna try and save them he's
gonna get mad at me
not gonna happen but then you had these
cops in new york who were guarding the
black lives matter mural
now i love this you know why the mural
was illegal
it was literally a crime to paint the
street
de blasio did it without a permit using
taxpayer dollars
and then put 27 cops to guard it
and people were protesting and throwing
paint on it and the cops would arrest
them
like sniveling little losers
imagine being as spot as spineless and
pathetic as any one of those cops in new
york
who's standing there half slouched where
the the
the mayor is smack talking you to your
face in front of everybody
and then you're just like thank you de
blasio i'll guard this for you now
wow it's like it's it's it's like uh
randall from recess that that little kid
was always miss miss finster and he's
like miss vinster
grow a spine be an adult stand up for
yourself
it was disgusting to see cops literally
arresting protesters
to defend something that was that was
spitting in their face
you got to be a special kind of pathetic
loser to get slapped around
non-stop by corrupt politicians and then
still agree to clean up their mess
and protect them from the mess they
created this is what bothers me the most
when kamala harris supports the riots by
soliciting funds to bail these people
out in minnesota ongoing rights for a
year
and then the cops are like i'm going to
protect her after that
where where where is any one of these
people with principle doesn't exist so
i'll tell you what really scares me
the cops that are leaving are the good
cops the ones who are saying i'm not
going to defend
these corrupt politicians these
celebrities and the ones remaining are
like
this the the the cops that remain on the
force overwhelmingly not every single
one
there's probably other reasons but
overwhelmingly as i said the other day
are the guys who are going to sell out
their own mothers
for cash they don't they don't care
about community they don't care about
this country they don't care about the
constitution
they just care about money and not even
a lot of it either
i mean man if you were gonna be a
pathetic loser
you there's so many there's so many
other jobs that would pay better
than licking the boots of bill de blasio
but i guess it tastes good
so you know good for them i think that's
by design man i i think
what these guys are black lives matter
and antifa
their their whole goal and narrative is
to
demonize cops right so i think
when they accomplish this i think that's
part of what they're attempting to do
like no matter what they do
they want to prove that cops are bad so
you get conservatives right you get
these
back the blue people that view stuff
like that what you're describing right
they see
cops defending black lives matter what
does that do
that paints in the mind of that
individual that wow these cops are
horrible
that in my opinion i think that further
pushes
their agenda and their narrative because
when you see those optics on tv
and people are experiencing this stuff
it further demonizes police officers
even if they're good cops so in my
honestly i think antifa and black lives
matter do
do that kind of stuff on purpose because
the optics of that
brings you to a conclusion to what you
literally just said to a lot of people
that don't realize that that's by design
i
wouldn't be willing to bet that that's
by design i'm in favor of abolishing the
police at this point
not for the leftist reasons where
they're screaming races or whatever
but because right now as it stands if a
leftist extremist gets arrested
the d.a will say sorry about that buddy
i'm so sorry the cop arrested you can go
home now no charges
and then you so much as fart and you get
arrested
and the da's gonna be like oh i'm gonna
lock you up and throw away the key
so the cops are like i'm just a new
neutral enforcer of the law
i arrest antifa and i arrest the people
on the right too and the people on the
right go to jail and get solitary
confinement and the people on the left
get let out and do it again
the cops it's the banality of evil
shuffling
uh i'll put it this way law cons someone
exercising their constitutional right to
keep and bear arms in a state like new
jersey
those cops with a smile on their face
will lock you up in two seconds
and the d.a will laugh as they bang the
gavel and say
shut your mouth you're going to prison
because you can't bear arms in new
jersey
you literally cannot bear arms new
jersey period
you th this is a state where they say
you have to have a qualifying reason
to be able to bear arms so pretty sure
the right to bear arms has already been
infringed
now you can keep them if you go through
a process and they're in your home
and they're you know in a safe and if
someone breaks into your home you run
away but you can't run away with the gun
just can't bring the gun outside so if
you're in your house in new jersey and
someone breaks in
don't grab the gun run away because
you're legally required to
think about the logic there no joke it's
in new jersey you have to retreat from
your own home
so what's the point of having the gun
you can't so here's what happens
how do you go to prison if you if you
have a if you're bearing arms in new
jersey
it is a police officer who will
gleefully arrest you
and it's happened it happens to a lot of
people a lot of good law-abiding
citizens
simply make a mistake one story i was
told is that in in pennsylvania you
could bear arms
and if you live in philly the new jersey
side is literally a five-minute drive
uh-oh
what happens you take the wrong ramp
what happens if you're in philadelphia
with your legal gun
and you take the wrong exit and you go
oh no i'm crossing into new jersey it
was an accident i don't want to be here
and then you pull off the bridge and you
get pulled over and they say too bad
that cops gonna smile as you get a
felony and go to prison
or have your life destroyed they will
smile and you know what i i'm sure
they'll smile
as they arrest antifa then the
anti-violence will get the
charges dropped and they'll get let go
and then you'll get to go to prison so
at this point
i'm just like the remaining cops are not
good cops i'd rather be responsible for
myself
if antifa can burn down buildings across
this country and get away with it
i need to defend myself and that's why i
started buying weapons to protect my
home and myself
as is my constitutional right and the
last thing i need
is a cop who can't enforce antifa but
will gladly lock me up if i try to
exercise my rights in the wrong place
sounds like it's more problem with the
da's because the cops are just
impartially arresting criminals whoever
whether you agree with the crime or not
but then the da's are letting these
people go
so it's putting the cops in a in a bad
place the cops are the ones who are who
are enforcing it
well they're just the d.a isn't showing
up my house and threatening to arrest me
no the va is letting the criminals go
right yeah so if there were no cops
enforcing unconstitutional laws we
wouldn't have to worry about the d.a
would sit there crying with no support
but wielding the power of law
enforcement allows them to selectively
enforce political ideologies and they're
doing it
so last year the argument was stand up
for the police and vote
when that didn't work at this point the
cops are
clearly just getting good citizens
arrested and charged and antifa is
getting let go
not just not just antifa but extremists
on the left black lives matter
these i mean we had in in uh portland i
think there were like
four people charged with felonies and
the feds
charged them and the moment joe biden
gets in all charges dropped
and there's only so so so then you look
at what's going on with
you know proud boys or whatever they get
they get arrested or or kyle rittenhouse
or chauvin i i think i think the show
thinks hilarious because he is a cop
but you look at kim kim potter so long
as the police are willing to enforce
this
they need to wake up and realize they
may be neutral enforcers of the law
but after the arrest the d.a is a
political actor who will let
their friends go and lock up anyone who
opposes them and it's only possible
because cops are doing it i tell you
what
i'm done with it the cops were unable to
stop the riots
i'd rather defend myself y'all can go
home now to all these cops who are
resigning these guys are good people
they're good cops they're respectable
they're refusing to suffer the indignity
and they're refusing to lick the boots
of these corrupt politicians
but the ones who remain these people are
crooked as they come
no principles they care not for their
community
they would stand there guarding an
illegal mural painted with taxpayer
dollars
without the approval of the taxpayer and
arrest people who challenged it it's too
i i think it's too extreme to make
judgments on on their on who they are
because you might have trash humans
resigning from the police department
right now yeah it's a generality
amazing people staying on the force with
limited options or
you know some altruistic motive ian if i
told you like if someone came to you and
they were like
you have to like brutally like
mercilessly beat a child otherwise you
have to be homeless which would you pick
my god i'm not beating a kid so what
what if they said you have to
here's an old woman who has a a a nine
millimeter in her purse
you have to lock her up for four years
in a state penetra penitentiary
otherwise you're homeless pick one well
i the cop doesn't
decide how long she gets locked up
because transports her to the to the
courthouse basically
yeah so so so let's see you encounter a
woman she's 65.
she's got a little snub nose in her
purse and you as the cop are told
either you are losing your job or you're
going to bring this woman in and she
will go to prison pick one
you got to bring her in why do you have
to bring a woman why if she violated the
law
and you're a cop i thought i thought the
constitution was the supreme law of the
land
well that it's a that's a confusing
thing whether it's a state law
do you think a 65 year old woman with a
revolver and a person go to prison for
four years
it's just a vague statement do you know
where she is man
minding her own business going to an atm
from her apartment she's scared
is it legal i don't know no it's illegal
it's illegal let's say it's a 65 year
old woman in chicago
and she knows it's a high gang crime and
people are shooting each other she needs
to go to the atm she's worried so she
gets a gun
she's walking down she robs nobody she
doesn't want a committed crime never
committed a crime in her life
should she go to prison i don't know
that's for the courts
you don't know no that's for the courts
to decide whether she gets let off or
put in jail
in prison the answer is not my decision
they're not the they're not the jury
they're not the
i think ian this is why i called you
evil before remember i said what
yes i called you evil this is the
banality of evil the idea that a 65 year
old woman who is not a criminal
who is scared of gang violence wants to
protect herself and is walking to an atm
i don't know if she should be locked up
for four years she shouldn't be
why should she be what did she do
nothing
that's just it's that's why we have
courts to decide that stuff i don't
think that
ian is evil i think that ian is a
relativist
which comes out to be a little bit of a
problem if you're doing something like
being a cop
because the fact of the matter is that
you can be a neutral arbiter of a law
but if the law is bad
you become a force of bad i'm sorry
that's how it works okay ian
there's an old woman and she's got a bag
of weed in her purse
should she go to prison depends on where
she is in chicago
i don't know what's the laws man it's
illegal well the whole go to prison
thing is up to the court to decide
there are mandatory drug minimums in
illinois
should an old lady who has a small
amount who has well i think they
decriminalized
but should should a person who wants to
imbibe a psychedelic go to prison for
choosing to do so
the answer is no i don't think
unequivocally
no i don't agree with those laws but
they are the laws so we have to change
the laws
to stop putting the pressure on the cop
cop
has every right not to enforce a law but
you gotta be careful with that if you're
a cop cops
can say go home kid yeah ma'am
you can't have that you got to get rid
of it you can submit it to
to to the police station you can turn it
in but you can't have it because someone
else will lock you up but probably if
you
how about when the cop in new jersey
stopped the woman who crossed the bridge
because
this is a story i was told that one of
the gun shops out there instead of
arresting her and char and getting her
and processing her and then her getting
charged with the felony he goes ahead
ma'am
i'm gonna give you an escort back to the
on ramp to go across that bridge back to
pennsylvania you can't bring that weapon
into the state does that sound okay
okay ma'am please let's go instead what
did he say
you're under arrest i gotcha and then he
brought her to the station and she gets
to go to prison why cause she crossed
the bridge
amazing i mean that is the banality i
mean that's outright evil
i mean the reality of evil is when a cop
is like i don't care about the
constitution
i don't care about morals or principles
i just think
who cares you get arrested let me jump
let me jump in this okay so
i just i just want to speak to police
officers right now and just give you
like a
a a real quick biblical perspective you
know
we we're living under an unrighteous
government that is
facilitating and enabling uh pure
lawlessness on a grand scale
regardless of whatever state you find
yourself in you know the the biblical
mandate for a police officer
is literally in romans chapter 12 god's
avenger
that is mandated to execute righteous
judgment
or justice upon evil doers so what i
want people to understand and think
about right now especially if you're a
police officer
you're going to have to really make a
decision and i know this is a lot easier
said than done
and i'm just giving you some kind of
like pastoral counsel right now you guys
know what i'm talking about
you're going to have to make a decision
right now whether you are going to
be a vessel of lawlessness and
execute unrighteousness under an
unrighteous lawless government because
that is what you are
literally becoming that's where america
is because they're not executing
righteous judgment
or you're gonna have to make a decision
and walk away
from what this system literally is right
now and like i said
i know that's a lot easier said than
done you're thinking about your family
you're thinking about your future you're
thinking about your kids schools you're
thinking about your reputation
but i got to be honest with you man like
in in terms of what god has called you
to be and to do you are now heading in a
direction where you are not
god's avenger of executing righteous
judgment on evil doers
you're actually becoming the opposite
you're actually becoming the evil doer
to execute
unrighteousness on the innocent so i say
this to say this is
you're gonna have to make that decision
as to what you want to be a part of and
what you become right now in 2021 moving
forward because right now things are not
getting any better
and you're going to have to make some
serious sacrifices and
and really you know place your faith and
where god really wants you to be because
you i mean how do you want your kids to
view you how do you want your
your legacy to become because right now
i'm gonna be honest this is what
separates me tim
from a lot of other conservatives like
in the movement i am not
a 100 back the blue guy these people
hate me for this
i get all kinds of messages the hell's
the matter with you what do you mean
that's what we believe
i'm like no no no because when you end
up in a police state who the hell is
the police right so those are my views
like for me tim i
agree with you right i agree with you
with what you're saying but what i want
to add to that
is police officers have to make a choice
i agree with you
what you're saying ian let me ask you a
question you said that it depends on
what the law is right
the cops should just follow the law well
no the cop
has a moral judgment call to make oh
okay so you know you're saying the cops
shouldn't just lock up an old woman who
didn't commit
why didn't say she he should or
shouldn't it depends on the situation i
mean that was
i asked you i asked you a specific
instance
an old woman going to an atm in chicago
she's scared of gang violence and so she
buys a gun and she has it with her the
cop
you know what's up should she go to
prison i don't know man that's up to the
cop really
would you arrest her not to prison but
to take her to jail that would be a cop
you know she's going to prison like you
you can't pass the buck you know she's
going to prison
so would you do it would you arrest her
for that i would resign as a cop
immediately if i was a cop
that's the point yeah i'm not i'm not
i'm not i'm not a kind of
you know you you know because you know
the point is
loading jews onto trains was the law and
there were a lot of people who didn't
know what they were doing but it was the
law they had to do it it is the
obligation
of our cops our military to defy
unlawful orders now we talked about the
other day the challenge is what if you
don't know what the end result is
now you've got a moral challenge that's
why i think the national guard in the
military would probably just follow the
orders they're given because they don't
know the full context
and they can't but when it comes to a
cop who's looking at a young person
who's got a small amount of drugs
or some sort and they think to
themselves i'm going to arrest this
person
they know what comes next they're not
making these people's lives better
now for the most part look drugs are
illegal and i'm not a big fan
i i do think the war on drugs is bad but
specifically around the right to defend
ourselves right now is my issue
the police are trying to arrest these
people they almost
always get let go and i'll give you one
more in dc
in 2017 several hundred people got
arrested all at the same time
i was in that group i got released
because i was calm and polite
talked to the cops showed him my press
id eventually they pulled me out let me
go
not only did these people get
their charges dropped they then sued the
city
after running around smashing windows
and setting fires
and they won a massive lawsuit the
taxpayer
is now paying the people who set garbage
on fire
set an immigrant's limousine on fire
which he didn't own it was leased
and they smashed up windows and
buildings got arrested
but they know the tactics and the
strategies so they said the government
didn't know how to charge the
individuals they couldn't
so they get their charges dropped and
then they turned around and sued the
city
and won sued the government and one
so my problem right now is
as it doesn't matter what what you think
the cops should or shouldn't be doing it
doesn't matter what i think what matters
is
at the political level the judges
the mayors and at the federal level are
control
controlled by the cult by the cathedral
and any cop who stands there saying i'm
just neutral arbiter of the law
you are handing people over to the cult
so at this point i'm like you know
whatever abolish the place i guess
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time